hi folks I just like to take back every
mean thing I ever said about Michael Bay
his talent knows no bounds boom aha
doppelganger I say thee nay whoops gotta
go Oh parting thought Phantom Menace
right for critical rediscovery Oh so
I've been scrutinizing trailers for this
new film that double stars jesse
eisenberg and jesse eisenberg which is
if you ask me like twice as many jesse
eisenberg's as any film can respectively
play you've got me thinking about the
age-old crutch of the lazy screenwriter
the evil twin just slap some facial hair
on an actor and poof he's evil only one
show has ever truly done justice to this
silly trope no no that one's a gimme I'm
talking about Garth you know Michael
Knight's evil twin Garth from Knight
Rider he was even more badass than car
the evil twin of kid but the saga of
garthe Knight was resolved in a couple
of 44 minute episodes if you're trying
to sustain the doppelganger story for
longer than that you need to dig deeper
an evil twin doesn't have to be a lazy
pro if it's well-executed it can
actually have something to say about
identity and individuality like this
show orphan black stars of versatile
lead actors who can actually play
several distinct versions and the
writing is good enough to make her
different personalities feel distinct
I'm not sure if it's jesse eisenberg i
could be the same he basically always
plays the same awkward boyish quickly
schlub and that's the thing right for an
evil twin to work the original has to be
interesting to
don't you agree that no self-respecting
adult should care about comics let him
know and let me know in the comments